like everyone across Scotland the United
Kingdom indeed the world I feel a deep
sense of sadness on the death of her
majesty the queen on behalf of the
people of Scotland I offer my sincere
and heartfelt condolences to the king
the queen consort and to the entire
Royal Family
there will be many opportunities in the
coming days to reflect fully on the
Queen's extraordinary life and service
for more than 70 years Queen Elizabeth
has been the great constant in our
national life she has inspired us on
occasion Comfort he does and always
personified values we hold dear
throughout her Reign she performed her
duties with exceptional wisdom
dedication and fidelity
Scotland loved respected and admired her
and by all accounts Her Majesty was
really happier than when she was here in
Scotland at her beloved Balmoral in fact
I have been privileged to observe
personally
I hope it will be a source of comfort to
her family that she spent her final days
in a place that she loved so much
this is a moment of acute loss and
profound sadness
it is also a moment of enormous
significance
the passing of Queen Elizabeth marks the
end of Anita
our nation is in mourning
my hearts and my thoughts and I know
those of people across Scotland are with
the royal family at this deeply sad
moment